here we are we are back with two of our
most popular guests in the history of
this
podcast it's true look at the stats the
metrics they don't lie we're here with
Conan O'Brien and Jeff Ross It's About
Time Conan was on inside that's right
the snake eats the tail uhhuh uh yeah no
six uh it's nice I we enjoyed it last
time we came on and it's like you put us
in a trance and we started regurgitating
the crazy story of how we amazing I went
from being a Simpsons writer to being
the replacement for David Letterman
which was one of the crazier stories I
will still maintain in the history of
Show Business yeah and I got to tag
along yeah not you were you were part
you were the radioactive spider that bit
him exactly that's right Jeff's behind
all well no wait Lauren's the
radioactive spider yeah and then uh Jeff
is Aunt
May that works it all it's all goes down
to this it's all in the spider verse
look into it you you had just gotten uh
the offer to host and take over for
Letterman and you said yes you hadn't
you took over the ninth floor it was a
totally empty office it was you at one
corner Jeff Ross at the other corner and
you happen to be there when Letterman
taped his last show down on the sixth
floor Y and so you went
down and you know it was a Powerhouse
last show Springsteen was on at Tom
Hanks and you went down I think and
Smigel Robert Smigel and and babo Kirk
uh you three went down to hang out well
smel was down there already he was down
there and he called me yeah Robert was
down there and he's a huge Springsteen
fan and of course Letterman fan he went
down and he called me in my office and
this is before I mean I didn't have a
cell phone I don't think he just called
me in my office where I was sitting
there alone watching the last show and
it ended and then he called me and said
you really should come down Dave would
like to see you which I thought I would
not I don't think I would have gone down
on my own but he said no he would really
like to see you so I went down I could
see you not going down on your own yeah
no I yeah it's not quite my speed you
were you don't want to linger out there
in the yeah and uh but anyway so I think
we covered all that I think I went down
there and well the way you ended it the
way we ended last time basically was Tom
Hanks who was on the show came up to you
and you said he he put a hand on your
shoulder and looked right at you and
said I I wrote it down uh what this is
NE what sorry what just happened to you
doesn't happen it never happens yeah
yeah yeah he did he did say that and and
then Jeff was saying he didn't stammer
as much as you he was because he was
sober uh I don't have my glasses on I
couldn't read I love that well let me
said let me read back to you exactly
said sorry I don't have my mon
in uh and then Jeff said they
immediately started tearing down down
yes they started tearing it down and
that was that's where we left last time
and you like yeah I think there was a
moment of walking around this empty
Studio might have been the next day but
everything was ripped out and it was
just completely empty we were just like
this is too weird Studio 6A was
completely ripped out MH and I
maintain we had if you think about it
now it seems insane to me
that uh I'm completely green uh I've
never hosted a late night show I've
never hosted anything
and um Jeff's never produced this kind
of show before and we're taking over for
Letterman everyone's upset because of
the way Letterman left they felt like he
was uh denied his rightful position as
The Tonight Show host so people were
upset about that to succeed Johnny
Carson yeah to succeed Johnny Carson
instead that went to uh that other guy
and then um so there was a lot of
Sturman Drang and angst
and uh yeah I remember very clearly
looking at this Jeff and I are looking
at this big empty concrete rectangle MH
and
it's um it's
May you could look up the date or I
think it's May it might even be late may
I don't know um probably late May sweeps
so it would be late May back then and
then sweep uh
matter so if you think about it we
already we had a premiere date set
because the Affiliates needed that which
was September
13th so we don't have we think about it
may is almost gone so we've got June
July August and then we we have three
months and then Test shows have to start
wow
and to this day I I think that's just
not enough time it's in you know and we
didn't have I didn't have
uh wanted Robert smaggle to be the
headwriter but he wasn't signed up yet
and it was a question of whether or not
that deal would even
happen uh we didn't know what the set
was going to be we didn't have a band no
writers no side kick nothing and I think
um you know I just did this uh interview
in New York with Paul McCartney where he
was showing photographs of you know the
Beatles in 6364 when they're coming to
do the Ed show and the point I was
trying to make to him was that we all we
all look at these photos differently we
look at them as here the Beatles are and
everybody knows it's going to work
out so we are watching it with that
bias
but uh and anyone now when I talk to
young people and I say well I don't I
didn't think I was going to make it they
think well of course you were going to
make it but there it's 30 years later
and they're going by the bias of all I
see is your right bouncing around
different places and you're just so turn
it off camera TV this yeah this tired
old shoe that's been around forever what
do you mean you didn't think you'd
become a shoe they think you're trying
to be modest yeah and I and I uh
if it was it seemed like it was a
miracle that we would ever get this
together in such a short amount of time
didn't you think so we had nothing it
was like two two of us maybe one or two
other people in this cavernous office
with no
nobody empty empty yeah and um did you
take turns getting each other their
lunch or probably did yeah it's your
turn I mean we didn't we really didn't
have any idea what we were doing right
um it's terrifying it's terrifying was
terrifying and I would go routinely from
I remember I didn't have
much time there was no time and so there
was this order of things that had to
happen which is got to get the
headwriter first and
I knew it had to be Robert Smigel
because Robert and I were very uh we had
worked together on Saturday Night Live
we had done this pilot look well with
Adam West and we could kind of finish
each other's sentences comedically and
uh I
knew we both had this very Crystal Clear
idea of what the show needed to
be and how it needed to be silly and it
had to be uh post you know I don't know
post post Letterman meaning not ironic
all this kind of stuff and uh but we had
to there was so much that we had to do
and I remember it was a while getting
Robert's it took it took a little longer
than we wanted to for to get Robert's
deal made September and then no other
writers were getting hired at that point
right and so we couldn't hire writers
till we got Robert on board and I
remembered it was just it's just the
bureaucracy of deal making and yeah back
and forth and it didn't happen quickly
and then I remembered at one some one
point I guy that worked at NBC saying
well let's just move on from Robert and
I thought you meaning this deal was
taking a while so who else would will
you bring in and I said there isn't
anyone else you know what I mean it's
just felt like there isn't another it's
got to be Robert and uh man well it did
have to be it did no but but it but it I
was
uh I was having heart attacks all the
time so did did you when you said yes to
hey I'm going to take this over and
I didn't say no that's a misstatement
because to to be clear there was no like
would you like to do it I auditioned I
auditioned for it which didn't think I
would didn't and then wasn't sure until
I did the audition and thought godamn
that felt right that felt really good
and Jeff was there and Jeff Jeff you
know was running it kind of and Jeff
came up after the you know monologue and
was like oh this okay suddenly Jeff was
looking at me differently like I think I
don't know if we spoke about it last
time but I remember between the two
guests I forget who went
first I wrote on the we had a script and
on the back of the script I wrote you're
killing and just slid it in front of him
right I thought it said I my glasses
were on I saw said you will be killed
you didn't even need glasses uh no I
didn't need glasses Jeff's a great
motivator uh but I was um so what
happens is they don't call and bring you
into room and go so would you like to do
this or not what happens is I got a call
that said you've got it you're doing it
uh you're going to go on The Tonight
Show tonight and be announced so there
was no so right
um and then there offer it just happened
and uh then it's uh and look you know
I'm not complaining because I definitely
asked for it but once it happens it it's
so
overwhelming and yeah we didn't
have I just was remembered thinking this
is no time at all at all anyway I think
a big turning point was um Robert's deal
got made then we could start looking at
packets everyone was sending packets
in and we were looking at them I think
the first person hired was Dino
stamatopoulos was the first writer and I
remember being
elated because Dino we liked his packet
he had never worked on anything he came
in and I remembered exactly which office
he had he had the office right next to
mine
and he went and he sat at his desk and
started writing down ideas and I thought
we have a writer that was he knows how
to write and he's writing something with
a pen we're you know like we're on our
way I was so grabbing at any any good
news I was busy running around making
believe I knew what I was doing yeah
yeah no but a lot of making believe well
there's one thing we needed was we
needed uh we needed a band and a SAT so
I think Robert and I
were really focused on getting these
writers and you
were you know saying okay because Lauren
Michaels is the executive producer we
got to get this set together and Lauren
Michaels had a designer named Eugene Lee
named Eugene Lee and who recently passed
away yeah who recently passed away
Eugene Lee uh um and Eugene and all his
you know he came with Keith and Leo was
a whole people from SNL had a lot of SNL
people helping us and I remember yeah
and uh and obviously which could cut
both ways no but no but what I'm saying
is they
they this began the first major question
which
was Robert and I both we didn't want
this to be like a an extension of SNL we
wanted it to have its own identity right
so all these you know when the SNL
people came in who were great and super
talented um one of the First Things We
Said to Eugene Lee was we just want to
make sure it doesn't look like SNL
meaning and and Eugene Lee had famously
come up with this uh design ethic for
SNL which was you know sort of urban
very New York very New York outside
spaces girs a lot of so we gave him that
mandate and that story will continue
later but uh so he goes off to work on
that um and I remember for some reason I
think someone had given me I have very
clear memories of certain things someone
had given me kind of like a metal
briefcase that looked like it was made
of like aluminum it wasn't that
expensive but I had gotten it for
Christmas like the year before from one
of my brothers or one of my sisters had
given me this metal briefcase it like C
like kind of like the kind of drug
dealer would use in an 80s movie and it
you know you click it open and you'd
open it it was just like this Cas it
should be full of cash it should be full
of cash and it should be releasing a
kidnapped
victim I remember really clearly I had
this office there was nothing in it but
like an iron desk that I think had been
around since like the
50s um and a crappy chair and then I had
that briefcase and I had writer
submissions in it you're all set but I
walked around with this iron briefcase
and I remembered every night I would
leave the office I would pass 6A and
they'd be in there
uh but there you should have handcuffed
it to yourself I know but but every
night there was nothing happening in
there yet you know what I mean it just
it's and every night it would get
getting closer and closer studio is just
still an empty and I I would go I would
go home and just think uh I mean I wish
I had used recreational drugs I think
that's the way I could have gotten
through it but I didn't I just ate
potatoes and fried beef the truth is
when you when you have a set when you
design a set nothing happens for a long
time and then when it's supposedly
done it all gets installed in like a day
so there was a lot of time where there
was nothing there and it's being built
and also we were
having
uh this
is I'm drawing a rectangle and I'm
holding it up and you can look this up
online but this is a rectangle and
here's those famous double doors that
characters walk in and out of right
there and the Letterman setup had been
you know I think whatever desk here blah
blah blah and then then audience here
you know and this is all the audience
and everything is angled that way right
of course
Robert uh was like wouldn't it be cool
because this isn't going to be enough
space for all the great comedy ideas we
have shouldn't we do it the other way
shouldn't the audience be here and that
way um the the desk can be here and we
have all this room
super wide super wide and I remember
thinking
yeah yes I agree so the first thing we
start doing is we start uh saying we
want to completely reorient the way 6A
is set up oh so it goes a different way
and of course we're dealing with Rick
lwin and uh who has also passed away but
was an amazing champion of mine and
Jeff's and the show and late night
exective just just a great great man uh
we showed it to him and he was like what
are you what are you talking about this
means you have like next to no audience
this giant long and Robert and I more
characters yeah but and Robert and I
were like well we just we want plenty of
room so that when when 35 characters
come out dressed as a pope and a mule
and there's also a cartoon character and
there's a zeppelin um there's plenty of
room for them and then Conan can just be
in the corner for the occasional guest
interview um you you also couldn't move
the seats there's no room for the GU you
couldn't move the seats they were like
built in like there you know there was
you know remember the rake of the studio
it's all like you know a huge job to
reorient the entire oh so that all
stayed in yeah I
believe I believe that the um yes the
way it was set up was just next to
impossible to change around and yet we
were what are we doing we have so much
to do right and the first thing we're
saying is um I know this is a great boat
but can we make it a car and there was a
lot of there was a lot of that there's
another one I
remember which is we really wanted to
not be in Letterman Shadow I didn't you
know and and Robert would say a lot I
just you know you don't want to be
compared to Letterman and you think well
there's no I'm replacing Letterman
there's no way would avoid that and
there was this sense that I'm going to
get killed by the press and everybody
cuz Dave is at the height of his powers
and I'm like an amoeba you know he is
this he's this fully formed Falcon that
can see 10,000 miles and canex Predator
an apex predator he's a Tyrannosaurus
Rex and I'm three celled piece of algae
that's just replaced him and I'm going
to need a million years to grow a couple
of legs and so
um uh the funniest thing was I remember
it was Robert's ID like we should change
the name of the show so it's not late
night so we were thinking and I was like
oh yeah yeah yeah so we came up we came
up we we start planning and then we come
up with the name that we wanted right
which was uh nighty
night really night yeah nighty night
with con O'Brien like like nighty night
which we thought was just really
cartoony and funny and Arch and kind of
peew Play and play and so we had a
meeting I'll never forget in this office
in 30 Rock not in our offices but a
special office that Rick had and just
where take you to yell at you yeah we
told Rick no we told Rick we wanted to
meet with him I don't think Jeff was
there for this I think he knew better I
think he was like yeah why don't you
guys run along and pitch that so we went
up and we went you know we're worried
about being compared to Letterman and
Rick was like well I have to tell you I
think you'll be compared to Letterman
what would do and I said well you know
we're thinking we're going to change the
name late night and he goes uh well let
me tell you something that is a we we
own that name late night uh is a
franchise it is a very popular franchise
it's been very good to us uh since uh
1983 uh or 82 and uh it's for 11 years
it has been a benchmark and I think we
own that we we would get rid of it
unless there was a spectacular new name
and we said we strap yourself in strap
yourself you're sitting down Rick
because here we go and we said we want
to call it nighty night with Conan
O'Brien and Rick start going and he's if
you remember Rick Ro uh Rick uh Rick
Lan's a very proper uh exec like he's
the cartoon of an executive again
wonderful guy but he's wearing a tie he
looks like a clip art yeah he looks like
yes exactly he looks like midw he looks
like he should be a pig and he's wearing
like a a tie and his jacket's buttoned
and he's wearing his you know his chinos
and his shoes and uh
and I'm saying it's nighty night
Robert's like yeah nighty night and Rick
starts to go remember this thing he
would do he starts think I was actually
there he starts scratching the back of
his head and Going H okay H and I think
he had thing and I think I could see
like he was tearing flesh and he went
okay okay I'll tell you what this I'll
tell you this ah it is late night it's
going to be late night it's going to
remain late night it is late night with
col obrien it is not going to be nighty
night and we like backed out of the room
and then uh okay so quickly our our two
first attempts to put our own stamp on
this are terribly misguided yeah uh but
then writers start showing up we start
finding really great people
um and I do remember um at one point the
sound effects guy what was his name
it'll come to me and right around the
same time we start meeting the crew and
he comes up and he says uh uh guys you
know I was the guy I'm this you know I
hit the the C you know and letman throw
the pencils through the window I would
do the you know crashing the crashing of
the of of the window the breaking of the
window so if you want to do that I know
how to do that and I remember a spell
going yeah funny because constantly that
we will keep constantly people were
saying yes I remember that and I
remember also hearing um you know you
can do top 10 list because that belongs
to NBC and I thought oh my God what are
you talking about as a creative
person I don't want to do top 10 list
and also I'll get like I don't want to
do it a it's great thing but it's Dave's
thing what are you talking about but so
you were hearing I mean first of all
there was it was so there was so many
misguided ideas we
had um some writers started showing up
and someone had a cat so we had a late
night cat that was living with us on the
floor which is completely illegal there
was a cat living uh you know uh in 30
Rock the the art deco halfway house it
was the art deco uh you know Shrine to
broadcasting and we've we're hiring all
the writers we hired had never worked in
television before mhm and so um but
Odenkirk was part of it Odenkirk was uh
came in and was helping
um Andy RoR I mean I've told this story
a million times but he we
heard uh from Jeff
Garland Jeff Garland said oh you might
you you should guys should talk to this
guy Andy RoR he's really funny he's in
the annoyance Theater in Chicago and
he's out in LA and
so uh I think Robert had met with him so
I had to go meet with him so I just met
with him at a deli like in the valley
and remember you guys eting borch he no
not you
guys it was a really hot day and I
walked in and I said you know I'll have
whatever I'll have a Coca colola and a
you know whatever a corn beef sandwich
typical Irish you know good for hot
weather yeah and um and he was like he
said I'll have the Bor and I uh
I said he sounds like Rosanne um but
then but but I remember what I remember
is immediately immediately and it's just
like a good date it was just chemical um
I just liked him right away and we
around and talked at the table
and I I left the meeting and I said I
called Robert and I said we got to hire
him and Robert said he hasn't submitted
a packet we have to see his writing and
I was like I don't know that we do he
just seems like guy we need and Robert
said nope we got to see his packet so we
asked for a packet Andy wrote up some
stuff we read it it was good and so we
said I was so relieved because once Andy
showed up I started to feel like we're
it's like Robin Hood we're starting to
get our people and we have a
cat and then it's time to it's getting
later and later in the game to start
Test shows we're not there yet because
we have it's time to see
a design for the set all right and so
right and there's been people off
working on this well working on the
design yeah so we had said
to um Eugene Eugene Eugene Lee uh I want
to say Eugene Levy um which don't get
Eugene Levy to design your set no Eugene
Lee and Eugene Lee again I will stress
Eugene very talented guy and he' done
stuff on Broadway and he had done all
those iconic sets for SNL really
brilliant guy and he came in and we just
kept saying what we don't want is the
Outdoor New York architectural like rod
iron kind of thing SNL SNL We don't want
that rent set yeah and so he came in and
he had this cardboard thing and it was
under um a blanket like a
blanket a waa he wanted to do a waa so
we get into a room and it was the room
that ended up being you would know it it
was the big meeting conference room on
the other end of the hall so we're in
that conference room the show is now
like has to Premiere in like six weeks
Test shows start in 4
weeks and Eugene comes in and he says
okay well here you know you know here it
is and um we're all much younger than
this guy he's like okay well here it is
you know he puts it down and he goes and
voila and he removes it and it's an iron
spiral
staircase it's SNL it's SNL it's SNL
it's the SNL set and he's IR instead of
actually leads to that set yeah but he's
also he's I mean he's telling us this is
what we I'm I'm going to
do and my heart sinks the minute I see
it and I can you know all of Robert Jeff
and I were just like uh and then so I
start to
say okay well the thing is it looks a
lot like SNL and we're really hoping to
go in a different direction than that I
didn't I don't think you got the whole S
no no what I did is I said to say like
we don't want to do the whole and he
said I'll never forget I I said some
sentence and Eugene went okay well when
he he was holding it he said well okay
if you don't want it then maybe you can
get someone else that and he tore it up
and like the wall threw it against the
wall and stormed
out door
shuts pieces of cardboard on the
floor yeah and we I know exactly that it
faces
South
it's now six weeks out the designer just
tore up the set he's an older guy than
me he's an he's an adult screamed at me
ran out of the room I looked out the
window and it's the closest I've come I
swear to God I thought I could just go I
could just like go out the window
because and I you would win the argument
then have Eugene come back and throw you
was the beginning of a few uh low
moments to come and there were many low
moments to come but that was that apolog
did he um well uh no not really right
not really wow
no so dramatic he did come back he
didn't really come back about a year
later after we were on the air we needed
a set so he didn't do the set at all no
Keith Raywood did the set oh Keith
Raywood did it okay so he didn't so yeah
we ended up now of course on our own we
made plenty of goofy decisions because
exit that decision and then what do we
do we talked to Keith Raywood and he
builds basically and again this was a
lot of at our Direction he was under the
gun and we didn't he didn't have time
yeah so Keith is this is not on Keith
and this is on us saying kind of what we
want and we get this um this this it's a
like a nice little room if you watched
the beginning of the show The Late Night
show um I still have a lot of affection
for it because there's but it looks like
a Dean's office and the other funny
thing is is the color that we went
wanted a lot of law
books yeah I was looking for any other
job at that point but the color color
the bit the color was mustard right now
here I am you always refer to it as a
mustard colored I didn't know I don't
know much about of course I don't know
anything about
anything if if I know one thing after
all these years it's put a guy with my
coloring who's super pale but has blue
eyes and red hair against Blue yeah um
it just works don't overthink it no say
the young idiots oppos of the who wanted
to reorient the studio call it night
night uh get a cat you know um just
making all these crazy decisions left
and right uh mustard yellow and um I
think it just I think a lot of viewers
when they ended up airing the show
thought I had John
you know I think his liver failing was
the most common I I think I think I
think we might have changed it like six
months in no we did no no no well I mean
you can see if you see those it lasts
for a while I we weren't worried about
we were more worried about us lasting
rather than we just thought someone else
would be on this set I guess was the
idea of asking for a new set was uh at
that point down the list yeah it was way
down the list but uh
um we get we start to get get the set
squared away uh meanwhile there's no
band I was going to say did you have the
band yet no no uh but what happened
there was I was staying in
Midtown and rioo Royal Hotel at the rioo
Royal Hotel and I have a I'm looking I
mean I'm under so much pressure oh so
you don't even have an apartment no yet
oh I have a hotel wow so I'm under a lot
of pressure you really weren't planning
on staying long it was under a lot of
pressure and I remembered I never get
headaches but I was getting headaches
and I'm up in my hotel and like trying
to figure out how we how we going to get
through this or how we going to hire
these people or how we going to shoot
what should be the sketches that we do
that are going to really represent who
we are right away and
uh I have a headache and there's no
aspirin I'll never forget I like asked
for aspirin at the front desk and they
said we don't have it so I went okay so
I went out and I walked down the street
and I run right into Max Weinberg from
Bruce Springsteen and he's walking with
his wife and and I recognize him and he
recognizes me and he goes Conan hey
Conan what he called me for 30 years
after that Conan and um we chatted a
little bit and he said I'm telling you I
could I I know how to make put this band
together for you and I was I just
thought well I don't I mean maybe he
does he got right into it with you on
the pretty quickly he had been had been
there for 3 weeks yeah he' been he he
was the one that stole the aspirin from
the hotel exactly and said make sure he
walks South no but whatever happened we
were chatting and he said I could do it
and I said okay well you know um uh you
know definitely we're looking and I I
thought I know that he had he was no
longer drumming with Springsteen
Springsteen had gone solo at that point
he had famously fired the band yeah he
had gone all Nebraska what's that yeah
no no it was just would be Tunnel of
Love okay um but uh uh he says he can do
it I don't know much and there's a lot
of craziness behind the scenes craziness
that would take forever to explain but
basically there ends up being a
um there ends up being an audition and
there's a couple of bands that are put
together and we videotape them we
videotape them and probably videotaped
four or five really so we're sitting in
there and I'll never forget uh John
lurry was one y what's the name of his
band John louz was it the Lounge Lizards
or was it band he put I don't remember
maybe was the band he put together and
they were really good but it was ironic
and kind of um very hip it was very hip
and very downtown and I remember like
thinking these guys are amazing and I
have a lot of respect for John lurry
he's great I remember thinking I don't
know if that's the way to go and then we
look at someone else and then uh I hear
Max weinberg's here and he comes in and
he's with Jimmy Vino his brother Jerry
Vino
uh he's with that crazy horn section the
Bas player well and and I you knew them
I the the Bamba and Pender the the the
the trombone player the Boma of year
2000 year 2 and and and Mark Pender the
trumpet player when I was di Russ's Road
manager like 10 years earlier they were
the horn they were the Asbury Jukes horn
section which she hired to go on the
road with so I was on the road with
those I knew them and I walk in and we
had seen each other in like 10 years we
it was like I was thinking to myself I
didn't say out loud I was like is this
like an omen of some sort they run into
these guys so they yeah they
sit they
uh they launch into
it and I want to
say they
played uh I think they played the Peter
Gun theme correct and I wasn't they
sounded amazing now I wasn't crazy about
that because that was a song that GE
Smith used used to play at SNL oh he so
a a sketch would end that had no ending
you know
grapefruits I thought this was a deli no
laughs um by the way that would be a
sketch that I wrote and then uh and
then but then we said then they said
they had something else they could play
and they played we played a few songs
yeah and they played this thing that
goes I'm going to remember what
is
C
everybody and it was and then it kicks
into this whole thing it does that and
then it kicks into a whole thing and I
swear to God I was like this is it it
was obvious and I leaned over to Jeff
and I said buy me this
band like no like no question no
I don't know if you remember this they
had a second keyboard player then there
was two keyboards mhm and that when we
got into it it was like we can't have
two keyboards right for whatever reason
I just Scott he shot the other guy no
joke uh but anyway um so suddenly we
have that band yeah and then I'm
starting to think like maybe there's
hope uh and we'll the band play for an
hour yeah and then um yeah all these
little building blocks start once they
start assembling had to oh and you know
Lauren I would weigh in on different
things
Lauren Lauren wasn't crazy about the
band right he he didn't have a problem
with the band he just knew that I was
hiring Bruce Springsteen's drummer and
he said the Press will go after you for
making a 70s move you know it's 1993 and
this is a he said 80s oh I remember he
said 70 it's like he he actually pretty
big in but anyway uh he said it's he's
trying to make a point he wasn't
thrilled about it and I think he was
also getting some maybe advice that to
go a different way right uh from someone
and we I dug my heels in I dug my heels
in on Robert and said it had to be
Robert and I dug my heels in and said it
has to be uh Max and these guys and um
which I'm sure took a lot for you to do
when you're there and already kind of
feeling grateful to be there you know
what's interesting not when you know
you're right okay like that's the weird
thing is if I don't know I'm right I I
don't know but when you know you're
right you're right you just you just you
s you just well it's also conviction I
mean there were stories later on that
we'll never get to um that decisions
were made based on conviction and not
anything much more than that yeah there
was a
real almost
uh it was in its own way very an
ideological show there was a lot of um
this is what the show has to be and
almost like a thesis was written yeah
it's well it was like if there could be
there could be a you know there could be
like a Bible almost written about right
this is the kind of Comedy we do this is
the comedy kind of Comedy we don't do
and I think I felt that way Robert felt
that way and it's got to
be
um you know Letterman's thing which was
so brilliant was there was the talk show
which is Johnny Carson then
there's the anti- talk show which people
thought which was more Letterman which
is ironic right uh and then this has to
be what's next and it was almost this
sort of postmodern right it's going to
be a mix of peewees playhouse and
SCTV um when we do false reality I won't
wink at the camera right and say like
Dave had this way of always letting you
know I'm David Letterman I'm not buying
any of so people can rant ra around
me it's all happening but but but U we
all know what's happening here and our
thing was he's brilliant at that it's
great but ours has to be if I'm in the
audience and someone stands up and he's
a sea captain I need to completely
believe that he's a sea captain or if a
sketch calls for me to be suddenly broke
and crying and wondering and and at my
wits end I have to really commit to that
you can't break I can't break and
so there was a lot we wanted animation
we wanted puppets we wanted real uh
silliness and what was really important
is that nobody was watching over us oh
right no and that's true we were I mean
other than Rick who was in LA and we
were in New
York we just kept going and nobody was
really paying attention and I think
that's that might be the most crucial
Point mhm that Jeff made that
because everyone even if I was not in
that situation and someone told me yeah
they picked a guy who was 29 when I
auditioned um and has no
experience and they picked a producer
who's done some work with the kids in
the hall but most of his work has been
in music
and there's no way that they're not all
over them but we were in New York and
most of the people are in
LA and it's still a little surprising
you guys must have given off some sort
of
confidence well at least when they were
when these other people were around say
I spent most of my time faking it and
making do what I was doing until I
figured it out you know who actually was
help Morty was helpful yeah Robert who
produced the Letterman show right at NBC
and then went with him to CBS right it's
a close friend of mine and I would he
would I would call him about certain
things and his basic advice was ignore
everybody that's the advice you needed
yeah cuz otherwise you let all those
voices in but there wasn't even anybody
really interfering it was it was you
know and also I think there was another
element here too which
is um if you get too close and it's a
disaster uh you don't want to get blood
and brains so I think there was a little
bit of a lot of that's I'm going
actually a lot a lot of there's me and
there's this feeling of like this kid
could get killed literally killed on
television in in a month I don't want to
be in the blastone and I don't want to
be in the blastone when people say how
the did this happen right so I'm
happy to kind of hang back and then I
remember another thing from that summer
was there uh some marketing guys came in
and told us what their marketing plan
was oo because they say no one knows who
you are so we're going to tell them and
it was mostly about how I'm tall right
and it was this whole they had these
boards like he's taller than average
he's 6'4 you know and um he could touch
the rim when heum exactly and
I we were that was another moment where
my heart was sinking and I was thinking
when people watch television they don't
care how tall you are especially
translate on SC Not really definely
doesn't we've learned that we've learned
that everywhere I go in life people
cannot believe that I'm a large man cuz
my personality is that of a very small
petty man I felt like I was like
personally I was a like a blender and I
was like the cover of a you know when
you when you make a shake and you put
everything in there and you hold the
thing on so it become a mess I think I
was that for a long time I was just
holding it all in one place so it didn't
and I was a pureed banana mess Robert
was some kale and protein powder uh Andy
was Marino cherries which are not doctor
advised um I remember some of the
moments I remember a lot from this
summer was
uh okay this is where the Ford Taurus
comes into the
picture I had left Saturn Saturday Night
Live and gone to the Simpsons about two
years earlier and needed a car so I
bought
a um don't ask me why I had saved up all
my money I never bought anything and I
decided I want that I heard there was a
Ford tourist that had a stick shift that
was kind of say no say no more was the
part I couldn't believe yeah and so and
I just remembered thinking this is so me
this is right up there ladies will love
this this is right up oh this is a real
panty
dropper this is uh I always had to be
that guy I couldn't just go out and get
like I had the money to
get you Knowle a nice BMW or something
but no I got a I was like wait a minute
an ironic car it yes I got ironic car
and I thought it was cool cuz it has
this special engine it's really it's
fast it's got a stick shift but no one
knows cuz it looks just like a Ford
Taurus that that a mom would like Drive
kids to soccer for EXA exact no who
knows a Ford Taurus sh that's what I'm
saying super high output it was called
the show and so I get that so then I
take that I have that and it's in the uh
parking garage it's on the souths side
of across from the Marquee of
NBC um right and I remembered I would
and I'll never forget the cell phone
would just make kids laugh today it was
this giant I was it was the first time I
had a car pH well I had one installed
and they were some of us would not
remember those days some of us would
Jesse I'm telling you you would laugh
really hard this thing it's really big
oh yeah and it's doesn't really work is
the other thing so I remembered I
Cur antenna the curly antenna on the on
the back of the right like a CB radio so
I would when there was a weekend I would
just get in that thing at Ford Taurus
and just drive because the city was so
much energy and nervousness and
everywhere I went people were like
you're that guy who's going to
die in a couple of weeks and so I would
just drive out of I saw him while he was
still alive I saw him you could tell he
was going to die um and yeah see so I I
would drive out and my parents had a
place in Westerly Rhode Island and I
would go there uh on the weekend and I
remembered Lauren would call
me you know to sort of check in on how
it's doing and everything have you run
away yet you know and really Max
Weinberg and I'm driving and I'm holding
the phone but it's terrible technology
and there's probably three cell towers
in the Northeast at that point so he'd
be like and the one thing you need to
remember to do is
and I'm and whatever you do don't and
whatever you do
don't and I think one thing you need to
obviously do is and um I'm also trying
to shift sure and you can't shift and
talk on this big clunky thing there's no
hands free so I crashed a lot and it was
just a big disaster and uh I love this
mental picture of you and then I went to
my parents house and they had this old
they had this white house with just a
little wh picket fence and I get there
and I'm I'm the show is in a couple of
weeks and I've parked my Ford tourus in
the backyard and I'm just sitting on the
front porch the next morning trying to
stay
calm and I'll never forget this I'm
sitting on the front porch with my dad
and there's this little white picket
fence that has little ivy around it and
I'm I'm just telling my dad I'm just so
he was like well you know I think it's
remember it's all going to be okay and I
started to relax a little bit when this
big truck came around the corner
misjudge the turn and knocked down the
picket fence right in front of us
crashed it knocked it all down and and
we're both sitting there and my father
went uh you should go inside you're a
known person now like I shouldn't be
there in case someone comes by they
might go oh wait a minute it's that guy
who's going to die in a couple of weeks
you know maybe it's was that his fault
it was at his fault so I remember going
inside and thinking this is this is an
omen that you know Lauren was like get a
truck in there and kill him Eugene Lee
drive up to it was Eugene we need you in
Rhode Island my set well you're going to
die uh so all things like that were
happening all the time I did get an
apartment that was right ACR I sublet an
apartment you remember it was 65th it's
right across the street from Tavern on
the Green right oh on the park on the
park but when I look out and I could see
the air conditioning fans and all the
lights on Tavern on the Green and uh I
used to look out that window and just
think I don't know I just don't know
um would you walk if I jumped would they
shred me right I know shoot there's a
great over them godamn you you're G to
ask did we walk to work because I lived
in that neighborhood also yeah you do a
lot of walking to work oh I bet it's a
great walk it's also a great way to just
grind through everything in the morning
and also it some energy it was
[Music]
became you know the walk to work became
the cold open which I think was really
important because I mean that's coming
later on but right um it's not time to
maybe go over that one yet but the cold
open for the show is basically me
walking to work and people saying you
better be as good as Letterman and that
was basically what I was it was very
autobiographical it was heightened and
made ridiculous um but uh it was very
true and it's very well done yeah I
remember when I watched that it's like
oh this but you just believe that's
that's why it was so funny right away
because you know that's that was what
everyone was saying also was also I'll
tell you this I was told in no uncertain
terms do not mention Letterman and don't
talk about how you're replacing
Letterman at the beginning of the show
and talk about digging in your heels
right Robert and I write this thing
where I'm walking it's you know it
starts with I wake up it says September
13th I and um people on I think we got
real people like John Tesh or whatever
to say like well you know Entertainment
Tonight You Know big day Conor O'Brian's
going to take over and he better be as
good as Letterman and then me walking to
work and everyone saying you better be
as good as Letterman and I just knew
that I needed to play it total cheerful
oh horse in C you know yeah the horse
you better be as good as lman bro broa
did it and yeah and then broa come came
in and did this great
thing where and I it was important that
I just be like you bet like super happy
and super cheerful and not breaking at
all and then broa said he would and he
was great he comes off the elevator and
he walks up to me he goes g and I just
want to say welcome to NB and it's a big
deal like for Tom and Tom broka was
close with Letterman so it was a very
cool thing that he did this yes he was
always great he was great he's a great
guy and he but he walked up to me and
went with that incredible voice Conan
Tom Brokaw I just want you to know that
you know you have my utmost confidence
whatever everyone heard him be he's
rooting for you and I say thanks a lot
Tom and then he says but remember and he
he screwed up his face and he went you
better be as good as Letterman and he
held up a we we told him this note but
he held up a Saltine cracker and crushed
it and then lets all the pieces fall
which is what a what a but that was so
our show I love that that was in there
cuz it's so stupid um and our show was
all about gravity gravitas and then
deflate it with a little piece of stup
and he walks off but also you you
finally get off the street where
everyone's saying it to you and you're
like okay I'm in the building now I'm
away from that and it's Tom bro and it's
Tom broa and then I the PE the part that
was dark but I think people liked is I
go into the dressing room everyone's and
I uh and you you can't see what I'm
doing and then you realize I'm making a
noose and I'm get up and I put my head
in the Noose and I'm just about to hang
myself when they say it would have been
Hollander Hollander uh no
you're on yeah it might have been H
Conan you're on and I went oh and then I
realized there isn't time for me to kill
myself right right and so tomorrow maybe
yeah and that's um I remember I remember
like playing that and S being backstage
and hearing
it kill like an audience really laughing
hard and that helped satisf so much to
come out I remember I was I kept
thinking I have to show this to lwin to
uhhuh uhh
and it's I know he'd be he'll think it's
hilarious right up until the end okay
and that I would know that that dark
ending he want to pull back that he and
and so we sort of waited as long as we
could wait I think might I don't think
it was the day of the show but it was
late MH when we showed it to him and and
I remember him going he he's like
laughing and then he gets to the end
he's like
oh and I go and and and and he and he
but he didn't like he went okay He
didn't say no no he went okay but he
went oh okay I have a really funny
someone every now and then someone will
find photos someone was taking photos
that day oh wow and so we're sitting on
Central Park West where the benches are
mhm um you know the stone wall is there
and the park is over the stone wall and
we're waiting for the next shot to be
set up because that's how I'm walking
down to to work and there's like you
know photographers from the post
following us and everything's just was
back in the crazy days everyone was like
wondering what's this guy doing what's
it going to be and but I'm sitting there
you're on a cell phone that looks really
funny because it looks like you're in
the Korean War Call like an antenna yeah
and and you've also got this curly fro I
had hair you had a curly fro and I
look 19 right and I'm wearing the style
at the time was this kind of big should
I'm I'm wearing a jacket but it's got
kind of like padding yeah
and then like this you know wide
tie it was just a weird transitional
time for men's fashion and my my hair is
this big floppy thing in front of me and
we're just sitting there and we're
making this thing and I was always as
anxious as I was and rightfully afraid
and I was always okay when we were
making something and so that's also when
we started shooting this is before the
premiere backing up but
getting close to the premiere we had
this idea that we want to do this kind
of because we were kids of the of' 70s
television um shows used to say you know
last last week on cojac and they would
show dramatic stuff so we decided we
wanted to shoot very labor intensive but
unrealistic things last week on col
O'Brien and it would and it would be me
saying to a woman I'm sorry my dear you
know I'm leaving you and she' throw
champagne at my face and I'm wearing an
ascot and it was all shot like Dynasty
or oh and locations wardobe and guns oh
guns and we worked so hard on these
things and um shots of me laughing
maniacally Andy Andy firing guns uh me
you know uh passionately kissing a woman
and um then someone jumps in with a
knife ex enter cut with car explosions
all this kind of stuff
and I the the whole time we were making
those I was happy yeah cuz I I knew how
to play that attitude I knew how to
play um frankly my dear I have to you
know that soap opera kind of
and pre-tapes you have all that control
over it pre-tapes you have control and
we were shooting them and God when we
were doing that or shooting the cold
open we we we worked our asses off we
were busy and we did a ton of
preparation yeah no we were busy I mean
it was crazy I mean even even when after
we went on the air it was crazy it was
we were there all you know till midnight
every oh we were never left well once
the show started it's just well that's a
whole other thing I mean I was wondering
leading up how much were you banking
comedy or were you a we were banking as
much as we could and I will say we
banked as given those parameters we
banked as an impressive amount and not
really
knowing what type of thing you know like
things were too long things were didn't
make sense you know like we didn't
really until you're on the air and
you're doing it as you guys
know you don't really know what you're
doing also yeah and we're we were
testing things out like we we tested out
Clutch Cargo which was an idea that um
Clutch Cargo was a terrible cartoon from
the
60s uh early 60s where they couldn't
even afford animation they would just
draw the the people and then they would
burn their real mouths in and it was a
guy real lips real lips and his name was
Clutch Cargo and he was like all right
we better get going and literally the
head would slide out and you'd hear like
footsteps terrible like and so we
thought it'd be really funny and we came
up with
some we were're testing out the clutch
caros we had a lot of ideas year 2000
was something that uh uh Robert's a
Robert
idea uh that we had done in
Chicago your live show the live show
there to a couple of years earlier in
the summer of 88 and there was a writer
strike and so we went to
Chicago and uh made this did this show
and it was people making predictions
about what was then the distant future
in the year 2000 you know uh pigeons
will be extinct and bald eagles will
darken the skies which just weird you
know like like Jack Handy small thought
small
thoughts so we knew we're going to do
that we'll do it with flashlights we'll
do you know we had all these we had a
lot of
ideas and we were shooting a lot of
content um we shot a really funny piece
where I mean Bob cus did a great thing
for us where yeah we show we showed a
clip of him yeah because he was doing
later with Bob kasus and he agreed to do
a shoot a thing where he's interviewing
the the the the old tree in Wizard of Oz
that has the old apple tree that ends up
throwing apples did a good job and he
was I mean there's a guy with great
comedy Bob kasus has great comedy chops
and he was really funny and along with
broa to get these these guys are
established I'm I'm the I'm the person
who really shouldn't be there and they
were all established and they were they
were fantastic yeah they were very
helpful yeah sorry go ahead oh we shot
something we had an idea and we started
to bring in audiences for Test
shows and I
remember that was fascinating because
people were coming in just basically to
see they weren't told what they were
going to see and I remember uh we did
him an ADH I think a bunch of them
really we no we did those weren't the
test show Test shows those were like
pre-test test show preest Test shows
where they set me up in ADH and I was
literally interviewing like anybody
would grab someone who was in the corner
right that was just for you to practice
I think Robert was saying that's where
you first played around with Andy being
kick ah yeah and I remember so we were
there and those weren't really those
were just kind of for us but then we
brought sort of bring in audiences and I
want to say we did eight of them
probably we might have done four and
four Cheryl Crow did one of them Cheryl
Crow did one and she was a
complete I mean talk about me being an
unknown I said like and who's this
musical guest and they said well she's
an elementary school teacher but she's
got an album coming out cuz she's been
you know back and backup she was a
backup singer but I think she also had a
gig teaching or something and she's and
you know it was I mean she's a bank
teller she's
blacksmith and I remember thinking oh
she's beautiful and really she sounds
good yeah but um she something yeah and
so she did a test show and we were
getting the craziest people to do the
test shows it was yeah uh Mickey Rooney
yep did a test show Grandpa Al Lewis oh
from the monster did a test show and
he's the first person we try to Clutch
Cargo out on yeah and so we thought it'd
be fun to have Herman drop down right
and say like oh hi Grandpa right and we
didn't tell him about this and what we
didn't know or we hadn't really thought
it
through um we we I think we mentioned to
him something like this would happen
he's like fine fine kid fine so
[Music]
um Fred Gwyn who played Herman Monster
had died like that
summer and you like literally two months
before and
so uh the screen comes Al Lewis is
talking and he's got his big cigar and
the screen comes down and go we got
someone you want to talk to and we just
thought it would be about you talking to
Herman we weren and he went right the
character the character and that he'd be
like oh Herman you idiot and they'd go
back and forth be a lot of fun he starts
immedately going what are you doing here
here you're
dead you're dead I saw you in your box
you're dead he said something that to
this day the audience just gets quiet
and he goes who'd you make it with last
night a
woman and I I'm like Andy's Andy Andy's
been who' you make it with last night
a and I'm I'm and then the guy doing gr
doing Herman Monster is like
Grandpa Grandpa how can you talk if
you're dead you had cancer you know it
was just and then first rule of improv
yeah first rule of improv is call out
death so the thing goes up and oh my God
I so there were I remember the very
we're going to Tinker with that the very
first test show went really well and I
remember being elated thinking this
isn't so hard yeah and then I think the
second test show was not good at all
that sounds classic uh then the third
test show was rough
and um it was a lot of huddling a lot of
trying to fix things um and then
eventually it's like oh it's tomorrow
wow yeah and no one no one saw the cold
open until then no one I don't think we
showed anybody the cold open which
actually became kind of a tradition
because right we I pride ourself on our
pride ourself on our cold opens and we
never showed them all those years years
all those cold opens when I would travel
shows when I would do the Emmys when I
would you know we never showed any of
that stuff to people we always wanted to
wait you didn't even want to show them
in rehearsal
you're no no like don't waste if there's
any magic in it if there's any magic in
it if there's any gold dust on that
thing just let it all come off and if
you really like it then it's like yeah
we don't need to test this right we
would test it internally sure on people
like the writers watch them or you'd
call in some yeah I'd call
Davis different people and and also I
should bring mention like there were
people that were hired that summer that
are still with us yeah so I remember one
of the first people that we
hired was Jeff came in and told
me uh it was just total coincidence but
he said uh I hired I hired Paul Davis to
uh to be the booker and I thought wait a
minute I know Paula because Paula had
worked at Saturday night when I was
there and I teenager I remember walking
in meeting
Paula in 1988 and chatting with her and
thinking she's she reminds me of my
sister Kate she's really she's really
funny she's got something she's she was
like quick and she she and I were going
back and forth and I was like I like
that Paula Davis and then you know I we
see each other at SNL but then I move on
I go on to other things you know and
then now I'm hearing Paula Davis and I
thought that's great oh good Jee I like
Paula Davis and then you came in and saw
me like
uh maybe just a couple of days later and
said I got us a I got us a segment
producer and I said who's that and you
said his name is Frank
Smiley and I thought wait a minute I
know Frank Smiley total coincidence I
had been at a party when I was on The
Simpsons in LA and there was this big
party and I got introduced to this guy
who was very very memorable named Frank
Smiley and I was and I was kind of doing
shtick with him just as a Simpsons
writer and a guy who does shtick 247 and
I remembered him kind of not like
laughing but not giving it up all the
way and then kind of giving me like a
yeah you're not bad kid you're not bad
and I was and so you told me you hired
Frank Smiley and literally I just know
him as a guy I met right a year before
at a at a mid Hollywood party where
there was a keg you know like some dump
party and uh and so things started to
congeal Frank Smiley still with us here
today yeah Paula Davis still booking I
mean it's 30 years later and I can't
shake these
people uh Jeff's still here just hangs
out I'm a bad cold
yeah you were the original Co just
there's nothing I could do to and then
um there must be there's a couple of
people who've been there almost long I
don't know who who else is in the Jim
pit was hired that summer to do music
and he still works with us uh on on the
podcast on the podcast Radio channel
anytime I'm talking to anybody in music
or doing any of that stuff that's uh Jim
pit and we um he was just with me in New
York when I uh interviewed Paul
McCartney for the you know podcast and I
think oh we've been doing this for 30
years it's crazy uh it's not late night
any anymore but it's all the same to me
at this point right so anyway that was
this gets us to it might be a good place
to stop this might be a place to like
the The Test shows all the madness we
haven't had our first airing yet yeah
the the first airing hasn't happened yet
um and maybe we save that for the sure
next time this is a good place to cut it
but I will say there was some crazy
that happened
there was a reporter I think from USA
Today who snuck in y oh and that's not
cool like you're not supposed to do that
chart about you yeah and it wasn't a
nice pie chart so this guy came in and
looked at a test show oh and wrote a
review and I want to say his name is
something
Frasier huh yes I think he was an AP or
he was either AP or might might not be
USA Today there was a lot of apologies
that came after that but you you got to
remember there was a different time time
because it was a time when a newspaper
critic like could like great amount of
power it meant something it really I
mean today you wouldn't think that much
about it your feelings would get hurt
but this guy snuck
in you know you don't do that for
Broadway shows until until they invite
the critics and this person came and and
wrote a review saying this you know I
hate this and they mentioned worms no no
but he didn't see that one but he he
uh and I think he said Frasier Moore
Frasier Moore yeah and he went after
Andy oh boy in a way that was not yeah
uh
cool
and I think I mean Andy could tell you
this but I think later on he reached out
to Andy to go like hey buddy and Andy
was like uh
no I don't think so man that was uh that
was not good but the The Test shows were
horrifying and then this gets us right
up to
I think we took the Friday off I want to
say we took the Friday off we had a
Saturday and
Sunday and I
was uh it's so funny because I was just
back in New York and I always pass the
old hauns and I walked right past where
I lived and I remember oh wow my friend
who I met in college I'm really tight
with Eric rif he hung out with me on the
Sunday and we like took
a football and just toss a football back
and forth in the
park just so I would wouldn't be alone
and I could unwind M and then I remember
us walking back and it's Sunday so the
show is going to be the next day and I'm
walking up to my to my uh apartment
across the street from Tavern on the
Green and run right into Eric mink who
was the New York Post TV guy TV guy and
not a bad guy or anything but just it's
the New York Post which is you know can
can be uh at the time uh can be real
tough and I saw him and he just looked
at me and he said are you ready for
tomorrow like here I am just trying to
and I have my football and I went yep I
think we're ready yep I think we're
ready and he was like well good luck to
you then and kept moving and I thought
well there goes my there was my fun
night out yeah uh but I will say that he
just lying and waai for it I know I
don't know if this is a just to get you
up to that
day I read a book slept like a baby that
night wow no idea well this is what I
remember we were that first show we were
loaded for bear and to this day you can
look at that first show but there's the
cold open we had so much prepackaged
comedy we also had so many great funny
ideas John Goodman lot of guests George
Went Drew Barrymore Tony Rand Tony
Randall and he and I were going to sing
adal Vice and there were going to be
Nazis in the audience crying and nuns
and I mean it
was we we just put everything into that
to make sure that that first show was
fantastic so I remember I just wanted
to uh it's there was a famous convict
who petitioned he like I don't want to
do life in prison Gary Gilmore in the
1970s he said I just want to be executed
and so they finally the Supreme Court
because they weren't doing any
executions anymore finally said okay you
can by firing squad in Utah and so I'm
going some there with this they there's
this moment for a while where Gary
Gilmore got to talk to his family and
everything and I never forgot this he um
he just looked at him one point and said
let's do this and got up and went out
and sat down in a chair and got shot and
killed and I remember having this is a
horrible comparison but I remember
thinking let's do this like if I'm going
to go out I it's time to find out it's
time to find out because I can't live
like this anymore it's been months
months of who is this guy what's it
going to be yeah I think we were blessed
by the short amount of time in a way
right yeah right you would F you would
filled the space exactly no exactly we
would have it would have been worse we
would have built it in the round we
would have called it night the cat would
the cat would have had Andy's part uh
you know no I I think that is exactly
right we didn't have enough time which
is as it should be yeah yeah yeah and so
um which is what these shows are those
shows are right they continued once it
started next time we uh we talk I guess
we'll go from we we'll start at the
first show September 13th 1993 yeah wow
night night nicely done beautiful talk
to you in a year got us out now I want
to see that
show